we need you, Russia needs you Thank you
very much I will not hide at different times I
had different thoughts Now you are right now is the
time when you need to make a
decision I will run for
the post of President of the
Russian Federation I think that the best
candidate is the
VNO I imagine I will vote
only for
I approve of his candidacy, he has the same health, the
man has
a lot of negative things falling on him here
and there and on the one hand on the other, but it
seems to me that this is necessary for Russia, I myself
consider myself a patriot, to some extent
maybe monarchs. That’s why I think that
this is how it should be, God willing, I
have no idea, but if I were him, I would
probably rest more there, my health
is 70 years old, the
person absolutely positively
supports the president, we support
our country, we like his position and all
that. Yes, similarly, we completely share it. It’s
difficult for Dana to say that I’m something-  then I’m waiting, I’m
not expecting anything
myself
That’s because I think it’s harmful for women